look around there are plenty of things  as well could do without immorality sin  crime it's time for a change  [Music]  I have the power to make the world to  make people better and I'm not afraid to  use it  I'm not afraid to kill  how and when it happens  [Music]  face pen and this notebook  [Music]  no one can stop  and chasing someone with a nickname or  face someone who believes that a  righteous path' ridding the world of  criminals but his brand of justice is  misaligned  by acting as a guard he himself has  determined to them  it's my candy no my car to find him and  show him what justice truly means  you'll never see maternity and referring  to description would be a wellness very  she cares if it's the last thing I swear  I am justice kill me if you can  [Applause]  [Music]  you